hello everyone and welcome to a very
special now playing I'm Tomic che here
with Kevin Bernard yeah when you say now
a very special i kind of think of those
like now here's today's social message
we're going to learn about Kevin drogues
Kevin's battle with alcoholism today no
today we're that's a joke you don't
drink you don't know much about me um
we're gonna play starbound which is made
by one of the four dudes who made
terraria the artist and his new team at
chucklefish and terraria is one of my
all-time very favorite games so the idea
of a new terraria like game is making me
very excited that's a long list of Tom's
favorite games I mean this is writing
it's like this in spunky in Dark Souls
and that's kind of like my favorite
games of the generation right so I have
not actually played this game very much
at all I'd played about an out in the
last hour just can I get myself familiar
with it so we're just gonna just jump
right in so this is more or less dije
let's discover together as we go we we
are so that I mean it looks very much
like terraria as you can see but and but
this one has very specific tasks in the
beginning so I had some things like I
had to kill animals with a with a bow
and arrow to get meat and whatnot so
this this one is just obtained iron to
turn into an iron bar very basic and I
think I think I already did that if i'm
not mistaken with the iron part so it's
like terraria with direction or gives
you it gives you an idea of where to go
and what to do from the beginning it has
more direction yes so i have an iron
here and I've or I'm gonna put or in
there and smelt it just I always want to
smell things I did it get a smelt master
tie know like I'm about to smell the
leaven and I only do five stole things
ah ok whatever but I've smelted it and
now I have iron bars which should have
like finished my
thing two times iron ore i smelt it in a
furnace you did that yeah I totally did
that didn't know where my iron bars you
have to turn it in somewhere maybe I
didn't actually grab it and that is the
problem I have to go like this and grab
it and now i actually have iron see see
how that works you can't just leave your
your iron in the oven good job you'll
need a whole bunch of iron bars to craft
an anvil so now it's animal time your
ship's engine isn't yet strong enough to
take you beyond the alpha sector craft a
distress beacon and maybe you'll be able
to make contact with a larger ship make
sure you're ready for anything before
you do though ah what the heck I think
it's basically trying to say I be
careful with every step so so i also
have a crafty hable which gives me
access to do more than just the basic
stuff you can craft and one of the
things I wanted to get I don't have
enough for that I was trying to do with
stone pickaxe before back you ran out of
wood planks so I'm gonna get some wood
planks so the first tool you get in this
game is something called Lego what is it
called maybe I should just hover above
it to matter manipulator and and so in
Terraria you have you know you have a
sword and you have an axe and you have a
pickaxe and it's like different tools
for difference I just totally pick that
fight by the way different tools from
different situations and the matter
manipulator is one tool for every
situation
I got meat so I don't have a pickaxe yet
but I can still dig because I have this
matter maybe later which is kind of cool
but it's also hella slow because it's
not it's not made for any specific task
so I'm gonna try it can kind of do
everything badly is that kind of how it
works yeah yeah kind of and I want I
mean it's not bad but it's you know it's
just it's not ideal oh man I want to
kill those things this is this is like
instantly so one of the one of the hooks
about this game is that it's like
terraria in space and you can go from
planet to planet to planet and I've
played this before before one of the
updates and I'd never and it was a way
different planet so now all of a sudden
there's different flora and different
Falana that I've never flora and fauna
flora and fauna yeah I'm gonna kill that
dude you see if you kill one of these
guys with just like a sword like at even
oh my god did I miss it like that I died
if you kill if you kill one of those
guys of the with a sword you kill them
and you get like whatever gold or
whatever you get but you don't get meat
if you want meat which you need to say
[ __ ] your hunger you need to hit them
with a bow and arrow which is kind of
fun I did poorly I apologize why yes yes
you did it what was actually gonna do
right now wood planks right I was gonna
go wood planks you totally remembered i
already cut down a lot of trees yeah the
firt like the first thing you do in
Terraria is I'm gonna build a house I
that guy right in the butt ok so I'm a
Slama terraria newbie and obviously then
a Starbound newbie whoa um so just stuff
regrow our resources are some resources
replenish or once here like once you've
cut down that tree is it just it's gone
so and the way it works in Terraria is
if you cut down a tree it was gone and
then you're supposed to plant a corpse
and that might be true in this as well
but I have to actually check to see
about picking up eight core
let's see what i have i picked up a lot
of wood from that I haven't grow wheat I
see it looks like you got wheat seed
weeps and coral creep kool Kris
Rosemary's so i don't know if i've
actually been cutting down anything to
regrow trees which is unfortunate what
is that so that's cobble stone and wood
planks so I guess it's raw materials
versus materials I've already kind of
done something list but yeah there's a
chance of those trees don't grow back
which is you know it's teaching you
about nature Kevin I'm going to do I'm
going to do some mining right here just
as I can
this is the part of the game that it's
probably not as fun to watch but is
oddly super engrossing inter area and
this he looks like he's peeing on the
ground when he does that you are so
vulgar I am vulgar you are so vulgar so
one of the change because like this game
there's three stages of beta and this
isn't like the first stage of data like
phase one which is which is almost like
proof of concept / stress tests because
I haven't included tons of stuff yet in
the game but I know it's just like from
the it's been a few weeks since I've
actually touched this game and in that
time like you you started going on a
home planet with nothing and now you go
in a home planet you actually have a
home base which is kind of nice and you
can sleep in your tent at night and cook
fires cooked by the fire that's already
there so it seems like it's already
adding some stuff that adds a little bit
of personality to the game which I like
whoa loves that jump that is oh my god
yes
this is this is way more fun than it
looks did he just freeze he's dead is
that and I didn't eat I got is that
guy's that guy's not dead but stop stop
stop playing too much like your your
need for meez might kill you go system
yeah well it's also killing you if
you're if you're if you're so afraid of
that sword might better to be alive and
not having it than to be dead and not be
able to enjoy anything at all I don't
understand what do you mean well I say
cuz you said with the sword you don't
get me right nicest knows i was joking
about not understanding i understand i
just wanted to do look at the gold my
funk the old right near this earth do I
have the power to fire you still no god
damn it why would you do that it still
looks like your peen it totally kind of
does look like I'm paying Blue Peter and
who knows what kind of fee because he's
a fish man i think i think i chose the
fish guy that's oh how customizable is
your dude when you start very
customizable you can even choose his
personality so i had i gave myself a
like a gung-ho swashbuckling stance cuz
that's the kind of dude I want to be I
guess do you think they'll attack me if
I don't attack them first
he's the matter manipulator I actually
can't use it on them oh maybe I can I
think seems to happen though oh now now
I here I'll run away run away why
haven't I hot keyed any kind of healing
aspect because I do have stuff that
would heal me too okay do it now well
you can okay so I think I mean they keep
the meat much must heal me right if it's
cooked I would think so yes I'm going to
put that in the dirt block spot because
the dark plot spot is worthless okay so
then I'm going to have a bite to eat
totally worked did not heal me at all
he's full so hunger and health there's
two separate things here okay well i
think i made bandages earlier that would
work swap it out with coals if you don't
need that haughton bar okay that's okay
here's the moment of truth there we go
that's it and I should have made more
bandages huh whatever whatever so I want
what's gradual a it goes as you as you
use it it's not secret tree that's a lot
supposed to be doing
peeing on the tree ping on the tree
until the house down I have powerful
powerful pew I've often said that about
you so they found sales figures for this
game yesterday it's insane right like a
million it has already sold more than a
million copies and this game is not out
technically did you know it's still
pre-release beta stuff and I was talking
to john carlo marentina and he was he
was guessing that hey maybe it has
something to do with like minecraft is
still like one of the biggest games in
the world and this is like Minecraft but
I think at this point like this isn't
really minecraft at this point like this
is based off a terraria and the love of
terraria right yeah I mean that's what I
think I mean minecraft is great and then
when terraria came out people sort of
talked about it that was d mine krause a
2d minecraft but this is now we've
gotten to the point where I think
terraria has its so clearly its own
identity right yes yeah nobody would say
at this point okay this is minecraft in
space I think we can really accurately
say hey this is terraria in space yeah I
mean it's an easy way to talk about
terraria but it's it feels really
different than just a 2d minecraft
someone who adores terraria doesn't like
Minecraft yeah you're weird you don't
like Minecraft but you do like bolts our
area is more of a game and minecraft is
more of like a like a like a Lego let's
basically virtual Legos and that's kind
of how I like cuz I like having these
goals and I liked having the bosses and
I like just feeling the progress I guess
and I'm not as creative as far as
building stuff I've sewed in Terraria on
games like this you usually don't see
the kinds of creative elements that you
do in Minecraft or do I know you do you
do because it's like okay and I'm
thinking about that right now in
Terraria cuz I'm trying to figure out
how to build a fortress to protect my
non-playable characters from goblin
armies and you know and I've talked to
Cynthia weird who are the community
manager she's talking about like I you
could just build like a floating
fortress and it's like yeah and put them
in case them in bubble basically you
know that you could be really creative
with that stuff
so if you're into terraria you start
playing starbound is it almost too
familiar I mean you feel a lot of the
time like you're just doing the same
things you did before it's like it
really is like terraria in space or does
it feel different enough beyond the
setting for so yet from like a moment to
moment gameplay perspective it's it's
very terraria but like as you might know
the reasons for area is one of my fav
game is ever is the sense of discovery
so the idea is so like everything in
this is actually knew even though the
core mechanics are the same so what did
I actually want to make wood planks I
want to make wood planks I wanted to
make like a pic access link which is
still I don't have enough need wood
planks I'm telling you have talked about
wood plank thanks man you already know
this is this is your this is your second
step towards getting fired that's all it
takes yeah I'm gonna crap look like 30
something I can make all these wood
chairs okay put in bed I don't know if I
want to say but I would embed so i'm
gonna guess I'm gonna get a pick axe
which is which is super exciting right
good for you that's what people want so
is there something else I really want in
here there's an so I can bake so I mean
the anvil would be really nice
oh my god see this is why I need to go
underground silver copper iron this is
why I needed a iron door iron lantern
later bed that sounds like a terrible
bed
that's we even worse than wood it's
harder than wood said I'm gonna put my
pic eggs and holiday spirits oh that was
like there's like a Christmas update
like the end of December what does the
holiday spirit do I wonder I could prob
with it right yes I wonder if it makes
things glitter who's that dude how God
he's got a lot of health Kevin of it
somebody just called me kevin van kevin
van poop was it was a sean mckenna
doesn't even rhyme if you're if you're
gonna do it right say things like kevin
van board or stuff like that come on now
i'm gonna hide in my tent i think i can
also pick some be defended myself a
little bit it makes me healthy to go in
my tech this is this is the 10th that
was just like on the planet for me
waiting for me to come it's nice i know
it's really nice it's very thoughtful to
plan it yeah and i'm going to you know
start tearing into the planets flash to
find some iron and copper but whatever
it's a pop out and then i can cook some
meat hang on a second I got a hundred
percent health before I go down below
all right so is is multiplayer yet
available for Starbound totally don't
lie I'm honest single-player server
because I am a coward so tell for people
and it's funny that I was the one coming
on to the stream with you because I've
never played terraria or Starbound and I
have vague notions of of what it's like
so with other players do you have to
cooperator can you actually can you be
enemies if you so prefer well they're
definitely be competitive there is
definitely PvP in Terraria but generally
these games are cooperative cuz it's i
don't know i think so i only played
samaria cooperative cuz I didn't I
didn't I didn't I didn't even have any
interest in doing competitive i guess i
mean the combat is really fun and
interesting if you wanted to get crazy
with it i don't know i don't know if
people in the chat play this at all I
wish I made myself some new torches I
don't have any light looks like your
skin has enough below that at least you
can see the ya around you well it's like
terraria in that regard and I also have
this but I have torches to that I'm but
I so when you have a torch it can be lit
the whole time so that you'll know like
a torch like I would be able to place it
places and then so okay it's like a
permanent like a flare or something yeah
I don't know if you've heard this game
is also coming to the Vita at some point
which is almost like this almost a given
right it's basically my dream game is to
have this under because Ferrari and the
Vita is just like phenomenal I can play
that on the train I can play that on the
bathroom in the bathroom you can do
anything with that with that Tom do you
disinfect your Vita when you're done
playing it in the bathroom
well my supposed to satis like disinfect
well just wash your hands or yes okay
good I mean I guess it doesn't really
matter to me I don't touch your Vita so
this is true now you know not to that's
true this is actually how you keep it
from being stolen don't you yeah people
just kind of know Tom's germs are all
over his Vita yeah I really like the
Vita I don't know if I've mentioned this
before you really do like to beat it oh
so I did while you do this boring thing
so what this is fascinating I down so i
started playing to vita games over the
break 11 that was new to me and one that
was old to me so i bought dragon's crown
oh so i play i've only played a little
bit of love breasts it's true chicken is
one of my favorite meals Oh God Oh
what's happened with the poison Tom
you've let poisoning move move it's
building up you got to get out of there
is it building yes Arnott's how am I
even get out I don't I can't dig up I
don't have a grappling hook because I
don't have a grab like how you just
start going as fast as you can going
where you did it you pull the Justin you
dug yourself into a hole and now you
can't get out you should have hit a
little like little side things to go
there you go there you go just keep
going up just do what you need to do
should get out of there oh you're gonna
die you're a nice bandage something it's
done
it done I think all the water on this
planet is poisonous which is bad for
life are you disappointed in me I'm very
disappointed in you I was actually
thinking of Justin's Justin's experience
while you were doing that it's like well
Justin dug himself into a hole and died
and decided he hated it not really he
just decided to who he wasn't gonna go
back right then so I things got a lot of
help or did have it did have a lot of
health darn it still has comparatively
speaking a lot more lon shele yourself
you want to show yourself don't don't
aggravate the monster meat raw alien
meats what is that is that a temperature
gauge I don't know about that I don't
know about temperature
I need to get my health back okay this
is boring what am I supposed to be
you're supposed to be better at the game
tom I don't I am very see the thing is
you are so tied to that stupid bow and
arrow because you can't you like do a
few swipes and then switch to bow and
arrow to finish him off or something I
just like you going like does it like
does the meat drop based on how most of
the damage was taken or how the last
strike I like to pretend that I'm
playing as laura croft and she's using a
bow and arrow on an alien world the
Abbess of the thing is you like to
pretend that in other aspects of life
too yeah Tomb Raider is great it is and
we've got the the new advanced tressfx
version coming I know which is later
this month but her face looks weird I
change your face for some reason Kevin's
got a cob on I don't know what that
means is that good that sounds like a
British thing well you you're an angle
of files that must be good I don't know
I'm an Anglophile but I've never heard
anybody use that phrase I've got a cob
on hmm when I think of a cob all I think
of is like a corn cob
yeah makes sense oh it's last strike
apparently so last strike what does that
mean of the oh okay so it's a last
strike is how you get the meat like as
long as your last strike is with the bow
and arrow then you'll get the meat for
it the mix-ins yeah I think so but
whoever told us that totally agrees that
is more fun to shoot with about arrow
right you tell me if it's more fun oh it
is what we seem like you seem to like it
because it makes you move around I like
moving there's motion involved yes a
little bit I'm getting some cheese just
two guys I need some what I like that it
sounds like a really fast axe there's a
thing scorpion why do boo why are you
fighting me I just wanted to be friends
everybody always wants to kill me in
this planet now headed to the
three-button
that was just murder oh you got leather
I got a leather fancy okay so i should
probably big in a way that's not dumb
somebody's like drink some Pimm's do you
know there's a place near my house it
has the best Pimm's Cup to read a Pimm's
Cup you don't drink why am I asking you
where does it Pimm's Cup it's an
alcoholic beverage I don't drink it's
very it's quite delicious some of those
things where you drink it and you're
like this is an alcohol it's just juice
right everybody who drinks alcohol
always has these things I like it's a
business because they don't taste like
alcohol it's like white in that case why
are you drinking alcohol because if I
drink orange juice I don't you know I
don't I don't feel happy afterwards oh
no why not I don't know I feel happy in
the sense that I feel like there's you
know goodness flowing through my veins
now you know who feels happy afterwards
Walter Lopez does he love orange juice
please from Florida oh that's true so
you better when people buy orange juice
are they in directly supporting
everything Walter Lopez stands for I
don't know I don't know how far does
that really go down the rabbit hole yeah
how far down the rabbit hole do you go
like if I drink orange juice does that
mean that I'm supporting Walter Lopez
and all that he believes in I don't know
what he believes in though yeah I don't
know what he believes in either he was a
marine right
I think Walter was him I thought he was
in the Navy oh I don't know I don't
remember which brand he was a military
man I was pretty sure was Marines but
then again Walter should come in here
and tell us what branch yeah he should
he should come in here and tell us
Walter Lopez bleezin the heat Tom you
also believe in the heat right now now
that movie with with Melissa no who's
that what is her last name listen
McCarthy yeah the heat you know the heat
what I Walter came in here he did Walter
were you listening to us while we were
just talking about you that's freaky
what branch of the military marine right
Oh an army guy okay we're both wrong you
were marine we were both wrong airport
or something they're born Air Assault
Ranger qualified aerosol like you did
you like oh darn i was told me it was
aerosol like you were just spraying
dudes I specifically Trey like he would
he would go to like aerosol training
every day and they would give him like a
can of aquanet to practice when I had
silver I needed silver good for you yeah
so starts to start for my distress
beacon
did you know that Ashton raised wrote
starbound arist yes what are you talking
about yes what are you talking about
it's a thing you didn't know this what
do you mean he doesn't write with for us
anymore by the way well I guess not if
he's doing starbound you didn't know
this why would I know this I don't
because I I expect that you know things
you should know what's hot and happening
in the games industry exhaustion raised
Jonas he's not Austin what I say
whatever Ashton I'm until I defeating
the chat right now really yes you wrote
this game what does that even mean you
wrote this game everything because we
were actually talking about the dialog
in the office and how are you do you
know how much money Ashton raised got as
a freelance Game Journalists he's
rolling in dough so now that he's
financially independent you can do
anything he can he can do things like
right starbound I actually was
commenting to Sean mcinnes about how I
like the writing earlier cuz like you oh
now come on you don't suck up to ash no
there's actually like a thing though
because like like there's a quest like
hey cook meat and then afterwards it's
like well either or not if you're
vegetarian go plant some seeds and III
there's a lot of lines like that it's
like it's really kind of I don't know
uh irreverence I guess oh you're so cute
when you try to speak English words I
yeah I mean terraria was not exactly
known for its great writing so that it
was nice having that little bit of
personality in there so yeah awesome
congratulations I can't believe in the
chat this is awkward now so I only say
mean things that way you're supposed to
do oh no you should be happy I'm happy
for him and I'm happy friday not only
did ashton raised right most of
Starbound he also wrote lots of great
reviews at gamespot.com do you think of
the writing and starbelly better than
the writing and bioshock infinite you
know what i did not accept the
invitation to be on this screen just to
listen to you [ __ ] about bioshock
infinite so they are tired of being
trolled oh sorry sorry once another game
Oh it'll definitely better riding the
GTA 5 wait was that the most recent 150
I stopped listening to it'll have better
right in the GTA 5 which was which was
very juvenile juvenile isn't necessarily
week or bad it was weak juvenile oh
really yeah I don't know how much he
played if it that was the bad part of
the game was any time down another mouth
the last thing I remember I actually
legitimately was laughing at it was it
was racing along with this woman who was
so into her jogging like it was it was
quite funny it was quite funny oh I'm
about you are a lot of people that like
it was it was a type i'm familiar with
ramped up to GTA proportions there we go
yeah give a torch oh thank god but i
only have like a few torches i wonder if
i can craft another torch right now
maybe I'll craft some torches okay
actually guba shoe riot you'd be
surprised how many people do not like
Bioshock and I don't mean just in this
office but I just mean in general
bioshock infinite yeah everybody likes
my job there is a lot of negative
criticism written about bioshock
infinite so there's certainly there's
certainly a very valid perspective from
both sides of the fence it's a divisive
game yes but nobody really defends the
GTA 5 writing I'm not haha yeah but I'm
fine with it i like I just like I like
games I like fun I like I thought GTA 5
was super super fun I just didn't like
the writing part of it yeah he actually
liked it more than gta4 why have GTA 4
was was factually boring and GTA 5 was
super fun so yeah GTA 4 was factually
boring it was just not fun to drive or
shoot or anything in that game not a
huge fan of GTA 4 if you haven't noticed
and is there like any other awesome or
around
I'm gonna backtrack I'm not sure I mean
I need copper still I'm so now don't get
yourself into a stupid situation i want
i won't i can jump I can jump yay high
yeah terraria has a nice little
permadeath mode which I did once and
then it was like oh I die a lot in
Terraria I shouldn't do this I started
gosh darn it Tom didn't I tell you not
to do that you did but I thought that I
wasn't I wasn't there yet oh there we go
just you've got to learn to dig up like
it's that Simpsons episode except this
time you can dig up huh see I like I
like how you're in beginning the world
ya see perfect nothing to complain about
nothing to complain about at all isn't
you undid some of your steps tonight no
oh man Ashton ray says that there's a
permadeath mode coming probably in the
next update I don't want it I don't want
it that's too hard for me it's way too
hard for me also ones this game coming
out and once it coming out for Vita I
don't know if there's a bin release date
announced I don't know any of the
guidelines for the beta like fate ones
phase 2 starting do we know this anyone
are we supposed to know this because
we're the experts that's people are
gonna be awfully disappointed I'm just
here because I'm good looking we do have
a p.i.p don't way yeah we do have ashton
raised and the chat if you have any
questions asked raised in white no date
yet Becca okay but he's just a
mouthpiece for the Starbound industry oh
my god that is it's a Starbound industry
at this point it really is if you have
enough dirt blocks can can can you stop
doing dirt blocks now
there we go look at right underneath me
is copper i'm gonna guess iron ore
bad guess yeah i really wanted copper
so the music in this one I hunter
remember who pointed this out I have
been Sean at first so the music in
Terraria was kind of like the zelda
theme like that kind of music and this
is aam bein and this is rom being and I
it's I really like the music in Terraria
but this actually might make a lot more
sense for this type of game since it is
so often you know this this kind of mood
it's setting so it kind of makes sense
we'll see it to me a game that you spend
a lot of time with benefits whether like
a lot of MMOs you know the same thing I
think it benefits from good but not
totally in your face ambient music yeah
like but I am a big fan when that
because this sounds like the ambiance
really fits really like the music that's
really well that's what it sounds like
like I always always have like sort of
an issue with fallout 3 and the fact
that it's ambient music sounded like it
belongs in a in a in a fan fantasy game
like it wasn't great from an art
perspective art or music so how the heck
do you get a gig riding for Starbound
yeah ash and raise tell everybody well
there's there's liquid oh god oh god man
you didn't see the liquid ah move move
move it's not going to come how do you
know how far it's gonna go do you do you
know the physics of geology
I'm fine you didn't know the pressure
wasn't going to cause that to go upwards
I knew I knew don't tell me what I don't
know how do you get a job writing for
Starbound where's chucklefish located at
in San Francisco oh my god why is there
so much poison water everywhere if you
hit the heal yourself before you poison
to death
there we go ah
or whatever the fishes in the UK which
is good because that's where Ashton
raises as well hmm i do not know they're
from the UK they might be if this game
is as good as I think it is they're the
best UK developer center was good
putting about that take that who else is
in the UK Batman team hold up yeah
that's not that this is this will be
better than Batman come on there's
already personal Batman team so like
pac-man are Arkham origins not or not or
not arkham city and Arkham Asylum I know
who rocks study is and I would I will
throughout steady that's who I could
remember their name terraria is better
than anything that that they've ever
done rockstar has several folks in there
yeah is the bully team in the UK i
forget which teammate bully vancouver
vancouver okay does the team that makes
katha tato is there don't kill me anyone
oh god what are you dropping a poop on
me for
I don't think that's pooch what else
would it be it was a bird and it was
pooping on me from above switch switch
heel and sorrow you are Tom you are too
aggressive in this game they're too
aggressive I thought verbally yes yeah
yeah what do you think like that I think
you're ringing takes one to know one
yeah it does okay you do have awesome
there are some awesome devs in the UK
though I know your case pretty great ah
do you know what also is great from the
UK old whose line is it anyway episodes
and also palmerton and climbing rope I
should probably have a climber those are
the two best things about the UK and I
could climb using a climbing rope if I
ever need it the platform I can't make
bandages cuz I don't have any plant
fiber so that is used
so I'm asking if I'm excited to play
double fine's broken age I am I'm weird
with double fine I've only liked one
double fine game ever a lot I could I
love psycho nuts but that's like all
that I really loved so I'd are now their
games for me their games have lots of
charm but ultimately I don't enjoy the
act of playing them all that much a lot
of the time yeah like I know a lot of
people liked what was the one with jack
black brutal legend brutal legend a lot
of people like your legend I I don't
consider myself to be in that crowd of
people that really liked brutal legend I
liked it but I didn't love it or
anything that game got real bad towards
the end I did not enjoy those like RTS
yeah I don't know I feel like it's I
don't know I just don't I just don't
only enjoy tim schafer games that much
that's weird because he's like one of
the big developers in the industry he's
an important guy but yeah
there I have to do that out what that
does a sapling oh I guess that's the
thing i could probably plant right
and that makes sense
you're not even and you're not saying
anything I it will it make sense that
you would plant a sapling and then grow
a tree from it does that plan something
it looks like it's in a little vase ya
know it well like a little self
contained or if I try to like it but I
do i do like space space but I'm also
super biased so whatever that was a
double fun game it's all right now oh
yeah that's true then early access right
yeah but I have a buddy who works on it
so I am biased but I still really
enjoyed it which is kind of short as an
early access game might often be that's
not Starbound dancing brutal legend was
awesome until it turned into an RTS
which was yeah an hour and a half in I
did really well no it took longer
because the RTS stuff was like fine at
first and then it just got like poopy
yeah I did not like that game ultimately
and I don't know and it's like stacking
I don't really like like it just gains
that everybody else seems to iron
brigade is that what it's called iron
Brigade yeah was it initially called oh
um iron something I don't think it had
iron in the name no no no I totally
remembered I wish Justin should tell us
he's the one that like that game a lot
of people like that game by any office
van loved that game I don't know yet how
did I spirit what is holiday spirits and
that's that bald again I think that's
pixels trenched I never would have known
that Thank You Justin calvert I never
would have remembered that and that was
a lot like that and it was kind of like
that other game right where you could
like the one with the toy soldiers that
you could I think it was actually called
toy soldiers was it I think so it's not
a tower defense game where you could
also be offensive and so yourself jumped
into the we just entered a very
interesting place is a I think this is
copper which you know was one of my two
favorite minerals oh yeah it is copper
but also what is that below me to the
left I don't know but it looks like it
looks is it the entrance to a dungeon it
might be it might look like it's got it
is that like a skull I see a skull on
there on the on the column so we'll see
I play this this is this it's going to
be an interesting year for me because
what's going to be my favorite game of
the year this or dark souls 2 neither
it'll be something you don't expect to
be your favorite game of the year that
is that really your prediction that's my
prediction ok is it can be terraria Vita
I don't know it could be something
you've never even heard of at this point
i know i mean there's also i mean just
for throwing out stuff uh there's a new
game by the dude who made braid which is
all my favorite games in every X when
that thing takes so much longer there's
a new game by the due to made Hank you
who from grade so nothing below that's
that's something big witness and then
there's uh i'm pretty sure that mew
genex is coming out which is you know
the team meet guys who made another one
of my favorite games and definitely
binding of isaac rebirth is coming out
there's a lot of games from like my
favorite people who make games go in
there what happened
the hell happened was that it like a
like an item to pick up an item there
what the hell was that what was that I
don't know I don't know Ashton raised
might be able to tell us I don't know
what that was what if I do this then I
don't know what that was am I gonna be
able to destroy that I don't think you
can actually destroy that yeah I might
be able to you can destroy anything if
you hit it with an axe enough not
everything was a shrine you destroyed a
shrine what does that mean I don't know
what does that mean though what does
that mean we've destroyed a shot a
shrine I don't know I'm total see that's
like it that's why i love these games is
like the discovery because there's
probably tons of like walkthroughs and
stuff already because people know me
people are a bit about this but it's so
fun to discover what to do and what's
going on Ashens like oh man you've done
it now I'll do what awful thing is going
to happen next or what wonderful thing I
don't know I'm gonna try to go back to
base I wish I at a grappling hook make
one
see you keep doing this to yourself can
I make a grappling hook and I'm like I
can oh man you've pulled a Justin
Calvert so hang on a second I can just
do this like pick away some stuff maybe
that'll work oh yay there we go see
that's why the matter manipulator is
hella sweet even though it's hella slow
oh dude run away run away we can for all
be friends every one of us can be
friends everyone everyone will be
friends dressing me out tom everybody
wrap arms around each other and sing
Kumbaya dammits you do sing you bit me
he's he bit you while singing Kumbaya I
wonder what that or is that I just
passed is that iron I don't know but
iron helps us play holiday spirit take
that Santa Claus okay so i'm back and if
i'm not mistaken i guess i can do this
get in there first I think the stream is
over in like 10 minutes I don't ever
want to stop playing this yeah i know
this is fun I can't want to do they keep
talking to Dan the Horak who's you know
charge of streaming and stuff like I
want to do almost I don't know if every
daily or hourly stream an hourly stream
just a non-stop stream cuz I'm Starbound
I really likes I I mean I really think
this game as a potential would be just
like just beyond oh my god Ashton is
saying there's a species hidden away in
the game and the you i can't translate
their dialogue fully yet but the longer
they've been in the game the more their
language parses and eventually they'll
be fully translated
what that's pretty crazy that's the
benefit to writing an in-progress game
and this is this is exciting so you got
any the process of the writing part of a
part of the gameplay mechanic Oh your
tree look I judges grow the tree wait I
gotta get the I gotta find a new I was
going here first so I needed not gold I
mean irons fine whatever I don't really
need it to be smelt I Bell smells it but
I needed I needed the copper to be
smelted I know you love smelting my I
actually think you would love these
games cuz you love a sense of discovery
in a sense of place and that's what
these games are things that I love in
games there's there's no reason that I
haven't avoided it necessarily it's just
that it just never happened a lot of
that we've had this conversation too is
that my free time gaming is often spent
playing very shallow things that don't
actually require a whole lot of effort
or thought because my free time is so
limited you know I'm playing so much
stuff for work that when I play for fun
i typically place things that I can
finish quickly and things that don't
require effort what did I want to
wasn't the end because I wanted to get
like that thing to let me fly far away
the distress beacon you see that in this
list it was down further there it is up
there ah I don't have enough pieces yet
wait what I think I was flaking on the
wrong thing before when I was when I was
trying to see what lose what I need it
for it so I don't know this so that's
right i wanted pixels ok so you need any
more weapons how do i get pixels that
work is that killing enemies you get
pixels i know i have pixel there were
little things that you chopped that gave
you pixels yeah where do I have the
pixels
so I know that I have them dead pixels
no hmm was that ship one over its than
the other the other list i think right
Vic souls are raw no I guess I'm wrong
oh well I know I've been picking up
pixels
I don't I thought it was just from
enemies so I need to kill more enemies
and I need to I guess I don't have any
pixels here I think I have an iron iron
bar by where are my pixels I guess I
have to go kill enemies and get some
more copper yeah do that I got seems
like a reasonable thing to do it up far
enough though I guess not like at me
moonwalk what do you think about that
you jealous and by the way pixels are
your currency so they're not an
inventory item up the top right did you
know that offhand or did you it is right
there and it says x 66 your connect
matches souls and that matches the thing
when you hover the mouse over it so I
did you I have to expect why do I have
to use pixels to make a thing because
things cost money tom but how do they
call I'm you i'm literally doing it
myself though I don't know I'd worry
much more about that poison do not dig
there tom I'm gonna date that I need
copper though I need some copper what
was the other thing I needed you're
always talking about copper well these
are how I get my my picture apparently
here I got a pixels
well these guys aren't carrying any
money seriously what kind of weird
aliens are you you've got some holiday
spirit right there can I just try that
in for some money I don't think that's
how it works I don't think there's any
transmutation but you will need wood
planks so make sure to take the time
every so often when you see a tree
you're getting into this you're totally
getting into this I can see it maybe a
little it's gonna happen so this game is
not early access team right now it is um
yeah it is along with others we're
actually in the process of doing all
sorts of things with early access stuff
so stay tuned was it yeah I think this
game is fifteen dollars i know i paid
fifteen dollars I don't know if the
price has gone up like Minecraft price
went up when I was actually like you
know release proper but I mean don't
want to just land on top of you when you
see it moving get out of the way we're
coward you're so you're so aggressive
when it comes to getting close to
enemies like you got to use position
see
man now i'm getting into it you're right
i know i need to play this it's really
so i can at least show you how to
perform the combat properly oh my god
see there you go now you're at least
you're starting to use position while
seat pull back the rope stand still dead
dead you play too much spelunky for for
this to be happening i play a lot of
spelunky in fact we're gonna have a live
stream of spelunky at four o'clock today
pacific time which is like five mins
yeah i don't know who's playing but
Chris Sean and I are involved and two of
us will be playing and one of us will
not be able just before is three minutes
away I won't be playing cuz I don't play
spelunky either I feel like I really am
sort of a weird one when it comes you
games played in this office because
people love spelunky and i'm the only
real non spelunker so you know what so
Sean just walk into the room and Eric
teh walked in the room I'm not going to
keep the stream going or how are you
gonna do okay we're just gonna wrap it
up so but don't go anywhere because
spine I'm gonna save and quit the daily
what the day no thing I absolutely love
this game so here's the thing steam
early access is often is sometimes like
a promise for something later and I feel
like starbound is immediately amazing
yeah there are enough games i think on
early access now that are good just
right out of the metal out of the gate
don't praise other games but this is one
of them this is what it's clearly looked
like something that feels ready to go
the ready yeah the gameplay feels
complete enough and polished enough and
so on and so forth so I mean thanks for
tuning in because I I know I had a blast
and I hope that you guys enjoyed
watching me take a whole yeah I had a
great time watching thank you for
joining I do it every day watching you
dig verbal holes so this is really
nothing this is very true so yeah thanks
Rach to Starbound
you